I am so moved and honored
by winning this prize.
I look at my predecessors
who have received that prize
and I am awestruck
by all of them.
There are people I have admired
my whole life and to feel
that I am recognized among them
is so meaningful to me and also
that this is a prize for
the study of humanity
that has really been
the foundation
of what has mattered
to me as a scholar.
Looking across history
and seeing what it meant
to be a human being at different
periods of time and trying
to understand the challenges
that we all share as members
of humanity and how those
challenges may appear
in different forms from
era to era through history.
So I could not be more
delighted and honored
than by the awarding
of this prize.